with will ferrell before we even get
into the game
jackie moon how are you able to even
focus after such an intense pregame
workout with jackie moon clay thompson
i mean we were uh
we've been in a tough spot with um these
l's we've been stacking up so
i was very grateful to see jackie i mean
i just remember through my rehab i would
watch semi-pro when i have a dark day
and that move would always keep me
keep me in the good light so i
appreciate him coming out and
what a hooper he could play look at that
the way he closed out on you clay you
had to be nervous
a little bit i mean i didn't want to
come under my feet or anything but
they were dirty back in the aba so
i didn't want to throw it out test it
too much yeah
clay when you have a situation where you
lose five in a row is it is it the case
of draymond's not here we're just bored
or you know my shot's not falling yet
what is it how do you how does a good
team lose five games in a row
oh
that's a great question i mean
it took a couple of battals prior to the
all-star break
our two guard
specifically me couldn't make a shot for
a while
then on top of that you know we had some
uh inconsistent lineups
but um to be honest shaq i don't really
have a good answer for you but hopefully
you know we can make win five in a row
here so bounce back time it's a long
season
clay man it's it's good to see you back
out here man um
as someone who's been to five finals
uh what are you what are you looking for
out of this team to let you know that
you guys have what it takes to get to
that sixth final
oh thanks duane that means a lot uh
first off got to get healthy
we're missing you know one of our best
players in draymond he's the heart of
our team andre and our big man wiseman
so once we see our team as a whole
uh that's gonna be a lot of fun i mean i
haven't played draymond in three years
and
it's like my brother and i miss him out
there on the court
same with andre and
um come playoff time but not even then
for these last 16 games we gotta
just create great habits because
when it comes to the playoffs it's
possession battle
and we can't have any empty possessions
we gotta at least get a shot up get some
great ball movement and be on a string
together defensively so
i'm really excited for the future and
this is gonna be a great year i can just
feel it
clay
like i echo what dway said it's amazing
to see you back out on the court
i think the thing that i have been most
impressed with with you watching you as
a player
is your mentality just being able to
step up you have that clutch gene when
you know even tonight
clippers were on a run you hit a shot
what is your mentality like you said you
have that confidence that that next shot
is gonna go in so what is that mentality
that you're taking now even though
you're struggling a little bit going
into the postseason having had this
experience and having that clutch gene
yeah
i mean if i'm gonna shy away from the
moment
you know what am i out here for like
that goes for anybody you know like been
through too much as a team
in my career
to be afraid of the big stage so i'm
excited just to just to have the
opportunity to play nightly again is uh
something i don't take for granted
and it's a process i gotta
find my legs i gotta find my wind and i
know
being off for as long as i was i can't
just jump back into it and be the
all-nba player i want to be i know
that's going to take a lot of time and a
lot of discipline
and most importantly a lot of heart
because
it's not just going to come easy you
know i got to
play within the system we got a
you know we got a deep team we got to
figure out rotations but
um as far as you know
that killer mindset i mean
it's just something that you really
can't teach and i think that uh
a lot of the guys in this squad
obviously have that
yes you do clay you also place up your
44th win of the season clay
congratulations man it's always good to
see you dude
all right thank you guys appreciate you
bro good job buddy
thanks shaq